cette maison en pierre abandonné au
milieu d'un champ à toute une histoire
en compagnie du propriétaire des lieux
on en fait le tour quand vous la
regardez à vous inspire quoi cette
maison la maison était là quand la
famille désourdy a acheté le terrain
dans les années 60 pour y creuser une
carrière elle était l'autre simplement
pour l'eau tout simplement dévié par
elle-même on n'a jamais dit monique
pourquoi sa patrie moi on s'est dit pour
le moment ne nuit pas peut-être que
quelqu'un voudrait faire quelque chose
de mieux que nous on fait présentement
avec on atteint
[Musique]
en fait cette maison était construite en
590 sur un terrain légué par le
fondateur de montréal paul chomedey de
maisonneuve un certain hubert lacroix
marchands de fourrure
donc cette maison hubert lacroix elle
était où
en fait elle était à peu près à
l'arrière de cette roulotte
parmi les maisons que l'on pouvait
considérer comme historique il y avait
une ancienne maison de ferme
or cette maison ancestrale a été
découverte par hasard au moment de la
démolition du faubourg à m'lasse pour
faire place à radio canada elle était
sans doute habité même quand les
démolitions ont commencé mais c'est là
qu'on a découvert qu'elle avait sans
doute un âge beaucoup plus anciens on
l'a confondu en fait avec ce qu'on
appelle les maisons de faubourg la
maison lacroix semble passablement
détérioré qu'on décide de la sauver et
les démonter puis rebâtie à carignan
avec d'autres maisons anciennes pour
créer un village d'antan en 1963 mais
quatre ans plus tard en 67 ce village
fait faillite
alors que faire de cette maison ancienne
at elle encore une certaine valeur
monsieur bombard au bon jour on a besoin
de vos lumières avec plaisir la pierre
c'est sûr qu'elle a des millions
d'années mais au delà de la forme on a
surtout affaire une évocation on l'a
démonté et remonté ça veut dire qu elle
l a perdu tout sur une authenticité
ça veut dire que actuellement elle a une
valeur de témoignage
ce qui serait le mieux c'est qu'il ya un
développement immobilier du site qui
permettent de mettre de l'argent dans
cette banlieue pour lui redonner une
toiture par exemple lui redonner la
ferrière lui redonner une fonction une
maison à l'intérieur d'un ensemble de
maisons qui ne sont pas des maisons
anciennes mais qui sont dits faire un
ensemble qui est intéressant mais le
propriétaire des lieux n'est pas chaud à
l'idée de toute façon le terrain est à
vendre
on veut en faire quoi
un colloque pour les gens qui viennent
faire du pédalo et l'idée de l'art des
ménages et sur son lieu d'origine n'est
pas envisagée trop coûteux pourquoi on
soumettrait pas à un artiste quelconque
une oeuvre d'art public qui commémore la
destruction du faubourg à m'lasse piste
le nom qu'on lui donnait avec le dd
morceau de cette ruine qui sont le
dernier élément dont on est sûr qu'ils
étaient là à l'origine en attendant une
décision sur le sort de ce qui reste de
cette maison qui n'a jamais été classé
elle gît sans vie au milieu de nulle
part
[Musique]